-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated
and Golden Globe
award-winning actor
you know from films
such as "Moulin Rouge"
and the "Star Wars" prequels
as well as his work
in the FX series "Fargo."
He's currently starring
in "Halston" on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-Halston, these are not bad.
-They're not good.
-Yes, this one is.
"Effortless and elegant,
Halston is an exciting new voice
in women's fashion."
-Well..."The look
they've assembled here
is thrown together
or contrived."
-Well, which is it,
Bernadine Mars,
thrown together or contrived?"
-This one says, "'You're eithe
young or old,' says Halston.
-Well, that's neither
good nor bad.
That's just a quote.
He never, ever gets to talk.
-Please welcome back
to the show Ewan McGregor.
Hello, Ewan!
-Hey. How are you?
-I'm doing very well.
It's lovely to see you again
-It's nice to see you, too
-Now I want
to talk about "Halston,"
but I want to talk about
some of your work
that I became familiar wit
over the pandemic that you
I guess, have been doing
for a long time,
which is narrating nature
documentaries for BBC Scotland
How did that come about?
-Yeah.
I can't remember.
I was approached
by the director of them.
Um...and I started
doing these narrations.
And because it's Scotland,
it's so close to --
[ Video glitching ]
...I just loved sitting ther
in the recording booth,
looking at these
beautiful images of my homeland,
you know, and nature and
the wildlife that lives there.
And I just fell into doing them.
I've done like four of the
or something,
four different series.
And, um...I like it.
I get to be David Attenborough
but the Scottish version,
you know, for a little bit
which is nice.
-You're very good at it,
but I do have
a bone to pick with you,
which is, early in the pandemic,
when we were
at our most stressed --
I'm stuck at home
with my kids --
and my son
has this book about birds.
He would pick a bird,
and I'd try to find
a YouTube video
of one of the birds.
We find the guillemot,
and I start watching this vide
of you narrating it,
and I'm thinking,
"Ewan's not gonna
lead me astray."
You know --
You remember this?
It's the most harrowing vide
I've ever seen.
-It's the most upsetting thing
you'll ever have seen, yeah.
-So, let's just show
what I'm watching
with my, at the time,
4-year-old son.
-Okay.
A razorbill
makes a final attack.
[ Birds squawking ]
[ Gasps ]
Unable to steer, it's headin
straight for the rocks.
Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, that is the worst -
-No, no, but listen, listen.
But listen.
What happens thereafter
is there's a shot of it
coming out of the water
and climbing back up
on the rock.
-Yeah.
-Right?
-Well, I slammed
the laptop shut.
[ Laughter ]
So I didn't see that part.
-There is a shot
that they cut to before
they see it coming back out.
Now, I know that might be
because it's not the same bird
coming out of the water
as when we just saw it
smashing off the rock, right
[ Laughter ]
So I said to the director,
I said, "You got to promise me
that's the same bird
'cause I don't think
that's the same bird."
And he assures me that
this is what happens in nature
They fall off.
So how do they
get down into the water?
Because the parents
try and lure them down.
They're down there, coming
"Come on, son, jump!"
And the birds are quite rightl
going, "[Bleep] that."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm not doing that."
-Do you remember what the name
of the young birds are called?
-No.
-Jumplings.
-Excuse me?
-They're literally called
jumplings, according to th
narrator, which is you.
[ Laughter ]
Probably making it up
on the fly.
-I know, it's so harrowing
But they're all of them --
Because there's such drama
in nature,
and all of the series I've done,
there's these --
You know, I'm in there,
recording it, and often,
it's the first time
I'll have seen it
is when I'm actually
recording it.
There was one with killer whales
and dolphins being --
Like, there's one
of a dolphin kind of --
[ Laughing ] It's a huge -
He's got this huge fish,
and he can't get it
down his neck.
And the fish
is coming out of his mouth
It's like a horror film!
It's just horrendous.
Anyway, it's fun to do.
And, you know,
it's a cruel world out there
-It's a cruel world out there.
It's also was a very cruel world
for all of us this year, and I
read that you did one this year,
another documentary for
the same production company,
in the sweltering heat
of Los Angeles.
-Yes. It was a series
called "The Stormborn."
Animals that are born
in a storm, like, in Scotlan
and Norway and all of that
bad-weather area up there.
And they asked me to do it
And, of course, then,
we all got locked down.
And I was in L.A.,
and I couldn't get
to Scotland to do it,
and he couldn't come over.
So I just said,
"Look, you know, all of us --"
Like we're doing now,
we had to adapt,
and, you know, keep going.
So I got this little sort of
portable setup.
I was doing narrations
for some other things.
You know, I was
in post production
for our motorbike trip
"Long Way Up"
that I did it
with my friend Charley.
So I had the microphone setu
and my laptop,
and I was able
to sort of patch in
and do this kind of work,
you know, narration stuff,
so I did it that way.
But I didn't --
I couldn't find --
There was nowhere
that I could --
You know, I've got kids,
and there was nowhere
I could find
that was quiet enough
without risk
of someone battering in
and, you know,
disturbing the recording.
So I had
this tiny little caravan.
-Sure.
-And we call it a caravan
where I'm from, and there
was this little caravan
over up in the corner.
And I managed to get in like
a little Wi-Fi booster in there.
And I just sat in there,
and I started --
I said to them,
"It's gonna be fine.
I've got my setup."
And we started in the morning,
and by about 11:00, I was
absolutely dripping in sweat
I couldn't --
'Cause I couldn't put
my little air conditioner on
because it was too noisy.
So I ended up in my underpants
just sitting in my caravan
in my pants,
speaking into my microphon
about the little jumplings
You know.
-Well, you're talking abou
Scottish winter storms.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, that's -- I'm an actor
-Yeah.
-That's what we do, Seth.
-Everybody said, they're like,
"If anybody can do it,
it's Ewan."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Hey, this is really cool
to play Halston.
Obviously, this is a very famous
fashion designer,
and you got some time --
Or, I should say,
you took some time
to get to know some people
who knew him firsthand.
-Yes.
I was really lucky.
I mean, there are some peopl
in his world,
who kindly sat down with me,
people he worked with.
But, you know,
the most amazing friendshi
he had was with Liza Minnelli.
And they had a really beautifu
best friendship.
And I wanted to meet her.
I wanted to meet her anywa
and reassure her that
he was in good hands --
he was in safe hands with me
That I wanted her to know
that I respected
their friendship,
and I understood
that he was
very important to her.
But I couldn't have imagined
you know, just how --
She asked me to keep
our conversation private,
which I would always respect
but I got -- what she gave to me
was the great love
she had for him,
and I could see through her,
you know, the great love
he had for her.
So, it was a really beautiful --
And then, it was very shortl
after I met Liza,
I went off and started
playing Halston.
It's a responsibility, you know,
when you're playing somebody
who's lived
and to get him right.
And I was lucky
that she was able
to share some of her memorie
of him with me.
-Yeah, I will say,
insofar as having to do research
for a part,
you can do a lot worse
than having to sit down
with Liza Minnelli.
That seems like as good as
it gets, as far as research.
-It was ama-- it was brilliant
It was brilliant.
It was such an honor
to meet her.
I mean, really.
-It is always an honor
to have you here.
I can't wait to see the show
And we are gonna go out
with a clip of the guillemot
crawling out of the water.
And then our viewers
can go back and see
if they think
it's the same bird.
-Yeah, yeah.
I mean, it's 50/50, isn't it
[ Laughter ]
Or maybe even the odds
are slightly less than that.
I don't know.
-"Halston" is available no
on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."
-But guillemot chicks
have dense, downy feathers
And incredibly,
it's unharmed by the fall.
Yeah, right.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, dear.
[ Laughter continues ]
-Thanks, buddy.
It's great to see you.
-It's great to see you,
too, man. Cheers.